hello my name is Maya I am a video
producer for petal-like and today I'm
going to be answering questions while
decorating some cakes so excited I'm not
the best at decorating cakes my
anxieties at like a 10 but it's fine
I started mine muncom which is a blog
when I was 16 years old
even back then when I was at 16 it was
so like I need to live in a moment more
and so I wanted like a Disney Channel
Nickelodeon type name so I was like how
about my in the moment I used to
practice doing the little Disney ears it
was really hi I'm Maya from my in the
moment and you're watching Disney
Channel
[Music]
Ashley Perez had her series called
unfortunately Ashley and I played the
ghost of Christmas future
or no Christmas present oh well Emily
and I never really done acting before it
was really cool I love chili there you
know like poblano it was that but it had
like this special sauce over it I'm
Mexican and I don't understand like why
we eat straight-up spicy stuff in the
morning like chilaquiles are just like
green chili or red chili in the morning
so I think I'm gonna save these lasting
cupcakes for later and start working on
the cakes
that movie with the the girl and the
like a dollhouse and she like makes the
dollhouse
I love unsolved
I saw the recent one it was called a
house hunting of Lois Lane and they were
like the way you attract demons is by
being vulnerable and alone in your house
and I was vulnerable and alone in my
house I'm making this cake with so much
love good intentions I love Mexican
slang we'll look at this chocolate cake
you would say like gay on the way it's
more of like fool whenever I say bye to
anyone who I know is like Mexican
American I always say I say Wachtel
which is like I'll see you later but if
you break it down it's like there's like
you and watch oh is obviously like watch
and it's something that like I love cuz
I grew up with that Mexican American is
like its own subculture you know what
that's as good as it's gonna get Jesus
stop calm down a couple weeks ago when I
got to sing at this concert that was
called Celina for sanctuary I've never
done it with a fool live band and in
front of like hundreds of people all my
friends showed up and some of my family
members like that was my favorite moment
seeing them in the crowd like supporting
me I'm trying to get that like sweetness
on the crunch like I said this is still
a fire sign cake so we're sweet but we
have that crunch you know here fire sign
you know what that means get it
I am a proud Mexican okay let your girl
does not like tomatoes onions or semen
on throw but it also doesn't make me any
less Mexican so now that I'm putting on
these gold flakes I'm thinking I should
have just left it blank but I have to
commit which is a fire sign trait that
we know nothing about commitment I think
this is done she's had her moment she's
a little lopsided but aren't we all so I
think I'm gonna put her aside and finish
the rest of the cupcakes I think I want
to keep with the color palette I've
never made a tasty recipe at home but I
feel like that's like your grandma gives
you a recipe you should probably do it
not saying tasty is a grandma
my favorite song right now is Cody
Simpson who've made this song for Miley
freakin Cyrus and it's called golden and
it's so cute yes so I've been saying do
the thing or about it like a year now
only you know what the thing is so when
I say do the thing will pops up in your
mind that's the thing you should do
I think my recent favorite Instagram
post has to be I was in Mexico and I
looked like a freaking spy so I made a
video basically that was like a spy
trailer her name is Maria dice Pia which
is spy in Spanish thank you for that
like thank you for sharing your story
because it made me feel more comfortable
or come to terms with certain things
that I've been struggling with I think
that's when social medias is at his
prime when we are able to help each
other relate and can heal those like
little traumas that we have we all have
them the last time I was in Mexico I was
like in this vibe where I was just like
I just heard the Mexican pop star and so
her name was Mariana and her long line
is hola me llamo mañana y voy a contar
una canción sobre mi corazon roto ser
Rocio means hi my name is Mariana I am
going to sing a song about my broken
heart
it broke I do this like character on my
Instagram that's like a mom who's trying
to get her kids ready to go to
Disneyland she's just like come on let's
go get in the car
we're gonna go to Disneyland and then
she realizes that she forgot the tickets
and that the tickets are for the next
day I think I'm kind of done and now I'm
going to assemble it the way I
envisioned in my head
it's definitely my mom who has her own
website in business instead of a
quinceanera or sweet 16 she bought me my
own website domain name which was my in
the moment
she's just been great on guiding me to
be very mindful of what I am posting
always make sure it has a message that
could help someone or make them laugh or
make their day better it's like really
cool and something I'm definitely going
to carry on to my children when I have
them in 100 years okay well this is my
cake I had so much fun making it
hopefully you had fun watching it and
learning some facts about me if you want
to follow me you can follow me at my
moment and aya in the moment and also
better like we have a bunch of awesome
videos and you should go watch them so
now I think I'm just gonna go share this
cake with them oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you